[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about a theory that has
been forming in my mind for quite a
while now and after all the clues that
we've been getting in the latest
chapters of the boku no hero manga I
just couldn't resist discussing this
important subject we all know that
all-4-one has the ability to steal the
quirks of other people and keep them for
himself or give them to others we also
know that all for one and the league of
villains have been conducting cruel
experiments on people in order to create
the artificial humans known as the nomal
although we still don't know how exactly
this process of creating a normal works
what we do know is that the nomal are
super strong and extremely loyal
servants of the League of villains and
that they can often use more than one
quirk at once but recent chapters in the
MHA manga have hinted at something
shocking and groundbreaking all for one
may not only be stealing works and then
implanting these stolen quirks into the
nomal he may actually be able to clone
and copy the strongest quirks he can
find and implant them into the Nomo
without actually stealing the quirk
which means that the original user can
still use their quirk at the same time
as a normal is using that very same
ability I will break down all the
evidence right now step by step to show
you how I came to this conclusion just
be warned that this video will contain
manga spoilers some of the biggest clues
are in manga chapters that still haven't
been covered in the enemy so because of
that please proceed with caution and of
course if you enjoyed this type of
content you can even like to let me know
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and Oklahoma smash
that notification bell shout out to
Oklahoma in order to really get to the
bottom of this mystery and in order for
me to explain why I think that all-4-one
is capable of cloning strong quirks and
implanting them into the no move while
still allowing the original user
keep their quirk we need to look at our
old friend muscular the roid raging
muscular was a member of the vanguard
action squad and he participated in the
attack on the forest training camp his
insanely strong quirk known as muscle
augmentation amplifies his already
massive muscles even further which gives
him superhuman strength and speed we've
seen that this quirk which literally
wraps the body in thick muscle fibers is
useful both offensively and defensively
because the Augmented muscle fibers can
make the users physical attacks much
stronger while also effectively
absorbing the impact of extremely
powerful attacks but why am i bringing
up muscular and his quirk now when we
know that during the forest training
camp arc he was defeated by deku and
then imprisoned by the police he hasn't
appeared in the story for a long time
and we can assume that he is currently
still in prison
and incapable of making a big impact on
the story so with that said what's the
point of talking about muscular now well
in Chapter 185 of the manga we are
introduced to the high and normal an
insanely overpowered nomal that also
appears to be significantly more
intelligent than all the normal that we
have previously seen this high and no mu
is even capable of speaking in a
relatively coherent way like the other
no mo high end is capable of using
multiple different works which give it
super strength speed insane regeneration
abilities muscle augmentation and Body
Transformation abilities along with the
ability to fly but what was that one
thing I said when I was listing off all
the quirks and abilities that this Nomo
has been seen using muscle augmentation
that's right the high-end Nomo can use a
quirk that looks virtually the same as
musculars muscle augmentation
giant muscle fibers emerge from the
normal skin and covered the body in the
same way that musculars cleric seems to
work from his battle with endeavour and
hawks we know that the high end normal
is the most powerful normal that we have
seen to date far stronger than the
average gnome we also know that this
normal was more intelligent than any
other gnome we've seen before it was
able to plan and use strategy and it was
even able to speak somewhat coherent Lee
this tells us that the Nommo experiments
that the league of villains has been
conducting seem to be advancing rapidly
and all of this despite the fact that
the mastermind behind the league
all-4-one is currently incarcerated and
under 24-hour surveillance at Tartarus
prison
this isn't itself interesting because it
tells us that all-4-one does not
necessarily have to be physically
present for these experiments to work
but it also tells us that there is
something more going on with these
experiments since we know that all for
one can steal quirks and pass them on to
others and since we've seen some of the
normal using more than one clerk at the
same time most of us just assume that
the Nomo are created by stealing the
quirks of other people and then giving
these quirks to the various nomu or
artificial humans but the introduction
of this high-end Nomo changes all of
this we know that the villain muscular
was taken into custody and imprisoned
during the forest training camp arc and
we know that at the time of his arrest
he still had his unique muscle
augmentation quirk we also know that any
villain what the type of quirk that
muscular has is definitely going to be
watched very closely in prison at all
times so clearly there would have been
no way for all-4-one to somehow get too
muscular and steal his quirks so that he
can give it to the high and normal and
I'm sure that if all-4-one had broken
into a maximum-security prison at some
point in the story such a major event
would have been reported in the news and
we would have heard about it the only
way that the high-end Nomo could have
gone a muscle augmentation quirk that is
virtually the same as muscular squirt is
if the villains figured out a way not
only to steal quirks but to somehow
copy or clone these quirks so basically
instead of stealing a single quark which
means that you take it away from the
original users so that they can't use it
anymore and then you transfer that quark
on to one single person
the villains may have figured out a way
to clone a strong quark allowing the
original user to keep it while also
allowing an army of artificial humans or
no mood to keep using that same quark
something like this could really change
the game drastically especially now that
the villains have access to chi chi Saki
aka overhaul imagine copying his insane
full metal alchemist quark and giving it
to an army of high-end nomu the
possibility of cloning strong quirks
would allow the villains to become a
critical threat to the very existence of
the hero society but maybe you're
thinking sure the high-end normals quark
was really similar to musculars quark
and even though both of these villains
just happen to be affiliated with the
same bill and group maybe the similarity
between the two quirks is just a
coincidence if that's what you think
then allow me to present additional
evidence to really drive this theory
home in previous videos I talked about
the doctor who treated deco as a child
back when Deku was waiting for his quark
to manifest but nothing was happening
this doctor appears to be the very same
doctor who is later seen working with
all-4-one which of course raises all
sorts of questions about why this doctor
was treating children and whether he was
actually using his position in order to
find new quirks for all for one to steal
now think back to when we see Deku and
Baku go as young children remember this
kid with wings who used to hang around
Baku go according to boku no hero extra
material provided by horikoshi himself
this boy is actually the grandson of the
same doctor who told Deku that he was
quark let's now think back to the
stained ark and the winged nomu that
grabbed Deku during the final battle of
that arc in the past horikoshi has
stated that there was a reason why the
winged normal grab
deku out of all the people there and
through one of his drawings
horikoshi hinted at a connection between
the winged nomu and the kid with wings
the drawing that he made looks just like
the boy from dec whose past and the
strong implication is that the winged
boy from dec whose childhood the
grandson of the doctor is somehow
directly linked to the winged nomal at
first i thought that maybe the doctor
was so insane and determined to serve
all for one that he experimented on his
own grandson and turned his grandson
into a monstrous normal if that were the
case it would definitely be the darkest
and saddest twist in boku no hero to
date and I personally felt that this
kind of twist where a grandfather turns
his own innocent grandson into a monster
was a bit too dark for ma chaîne I mean
the story so far has definitely had some
dark and gruesome turns but having an
innocent boy turned into a monster by
his own grandfather and then brutally
murdered by stain seems like a step too
far for me however my theory about the
villains having the ability to clone
strong quirks offers another possibility
maybe the doctor didn't turn his own
grandson into a gnome
maybe he simply cloned or copied his
grandsons quirk and gave it to a random
normal just like the high-end gnome who
seems to have somehow gotten musculars
quirk even though we know that muscular
didn't have his quirk stolen this would
mean that the connection between the kid
from Bakugan deck whose childhood and
the winged nomal is real but they are
connected because the Noma was given a
copy of the boy's quirk not because the
boy actually became the gnome the
ability to cloak works would also go a
long way in explaining why a doctor who
works for all-4-one would be treating
children if the doctor was treating
children who already had works and
allowing all four want to steal the best
ones then obviously the children and
their parents would notice that
something was wrong
they would notice that their child
suddenly no longer had a quirk after
seeing this specific doctor SOI would be
practically impossible for this doctor
to hide his true intentions for long but
if the doctor is able to clone quirks
instead of stealing them then he could
copy the strongest quirks that the
children had and implant them into the
normal without the children ever
realizing that anything had happened
because their own quirk would still be
intact and one final clue and the story
really stood out to me as well and that
is the Curious Case of ug Co Fujiko is a
villain that we still haven't even seen
but this villain was the one who allowed
Dobby to escape the scene following the
fight between the high and Noble and
endeavour and hawks and would Yuko did
this by using a quirk that creates
portals which teleport people from one
location to another
the quirk creates a foul-smelling black
liquid which turns into a portal and
multiple portals can be created at once
in order to teleport multiple people
from on location to another but the
mysterious person whom Dobby calls ug Co
is not the only individual we've seen
using this quirk if you think back to
the hideout Rea dark
all-4-one uses this exact same quirk to
teleport the nomu into the hideout and
to teleport Bakura and the villains out
of it if all for one simply stole this
quirk from someone then the fact that he
is currently in a maximum-security
prison being monitored all the time
means that he couldn't possibly have
been the one who warped Dobby away from
endeavour and hawks so the fact that
there is another villain called Fujiko
who can use this same quirk as all-4-one
did during the hyda raid are clearly
hints at the fact that all for one and
the villains don't only steal quirks but
also clone and duplicate them in order
to allow multiple users to use them at
the same time since we haven't seen this
person yet we don't even know whether ug
Co is also a know more like high end or
whether you Joe is just a normal
person but when we consider muscle
augmentation the winged no move and
uijik oh it seems clear that strong
quirks are being cloned by the villains
and given to multiple users at once and
if this is true then we can expect the
jobs of pro heroes to get much harder in
the future
the villains including the nomu are
going to be using incredibly strong
works that have been duplicated and
given to multiple users just imagine a
nomu that can use overhauls quark judogi
DS quark and Dhabi's quark at the same
time insanely overpowered and on top of
that the normal are getting more
intelligent and strategic which means
that the students and pro heroes are
about to face their greatest challenge
yet and personally I can't wait to see
where the plot of boku no hero goes next
please let me know what you guys think
do you agree with my theory that the
villains are somehow cloning and
duplicating works and this is why we see
that a Nomo can use musculars quark
even though muscular still has as quark
and is currently locked away in a
maximum-security prison or maybe you
think that it's all just a coincidence
and there is another explanation for all
of this
either way please let me know down below
I'd love to hear your feedback if you
enjoyed this type of content and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and Oklahoma
smash that notification bell and if you
want to keep up to date on all the
latest content and give us input for
future videos please follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar as
always thank you all so much for
watching it really means a lot to me and
until next time see us face cowboys
[Music]
you